I'm James Powell we're at PI data DC
it's Sunday November 17 2018 if you like
this talk you can follow me on Twitter
at don't use this code I am joined today
by two people two suckers who are
willing to participate in this talk
we're willing to help me write this talk
in to brainstorm it Dan Allen and
Brandon burrows and they'll briefly be
kind of introducing themselves but
before we get started I want to start
with the question for this talk
something that we've all heard somebody
say at some point in our lives why do
you have to make it so complicated
for example the audio people why not to
make it so complicated to turn off music
but it's the way the world is now this
is this is very reminiscent of maybe
other questions that we ask or answer
that have very be contextualized or very
hard answers like but but fundamentally
what I want to draw your attention to
it's a very different kind of talk than
what I give usually the kind of talks
that I give are useless because I'm
showing you something code wise that you
don't really care about this is a talk
that is you can take your music
everywhere you go no connection no
problem maybe tracks everywhere tap on
the banner to learn more perfect thank
you
[Music]
okay I think we're ready to go okay
so there's a very different kind of talk
than usual I thought that instead of
making a talk that was useless because
the code that I showed you wasn't
something you'd ever do in production
I'd give a talk that was useless because
the concepts that I show you really
don't go much of anywhere now when
coming up with this one of the things
that I was reminded of was a question
that we had answered very successfully
in previous talks that given what's the
difference being good code and bad code
does anyone know the different seen good
code and bad code it's very very easy
answer yeah good code is code I wrote
bad code is code you wrote so when you
talk about sophistication or complexity
it's the same thing the complexity in
your code is unnecessary but the
complexity and my code is justified and
this is really not a very good answer or
maybe it's not the best answer because
if you think about the best answer to
this question it's nuanced it's
contextualized it's specific to the to a
working environment in which you work
and it's very personalized and so that's
why we can so trivially make fun of
these questions because the real answer
there is no one guideline or one metric
instead what I thought we would do in
this talk was we brainstorm some ways to
maybe communicate issues of
sophistication using a framework that
Dan and myself had been talking about
for the last few months over the course
of a couple of different talks at a
couple of different events you can think
that instead of coming up with a good
take-home message for this talk I
thought we could call this crowdsourcing
to take home when I become a management
consultant that's what this talk will be
cut will be titled and so yeah and so
let's get started with the handout Dan
and Brandon will be handing out a little
survey to you it's two pages and we'll
explain what the handout is there's a
bunch of pens and ideally this will be
an opportunity to kind of play with the
handout and to think what this tells us
about complexity or sophistication this
handout is not intended to be a survey
where we collect the data and that data
is then plotted or we put it into a
machine learning algorithm or we try to
make a decision off of it rather it's
intended to be a tool which we use in
order to maybe communicate or understand
the topic better it's a tool that we
might use in order to set the tone at an
organ
which we work or set the baseline for
the culture that we want when we're
working it's maybe a tool that helps us
understand the topic better ourselves
and so I know Dan and Brandon are still
handing out the handout but I'll explain
to you how it works the purpose of this
handout is to encourage you to think
about these topics in a different way to
come up with some framework very
imperfect and a very flawed framework
for you to think about this topic in
order to try to better understand it or
at least put into words things which you
have some natural reaction to and it's
also to try and figure out ways that we
can communicate this topic to our
co-workers or the people that we work
with it's a very interactive exercise as
we've tried this exercise today so far
with four or five people and in each
case it was more like a personality test
wherein you fill it out and then you
talk to the psychologists and
psychologists asks you so how come you
put that one there because we don't have
the opportunity to interact with each
other one-on-one during this session I
would encourage you to work with the
person sitting next to you or if you
like the survey tweet at me with your
results if your results are interesting
in any fashion or if you feel they're
different or if you came up with
something what you thought kind of
breaks the mold before we look at the
survey I want to say that it's very
contextualized to how you work so one of
the things I want you to think about is
do you work in industry or academia so
Dan who filled out the survey earlier
works somewhere between both industry
and academia and Brandon works in
industry wouldn't we say the word users
do you think of end users just people
who take point-and-click software and
use that do you think about analysts who
may take code and build or take models
that you've developed and build analyses
off of that do you think about
scientists who might be running
experiments based off the code that you
write do you think about other code
users people who take your code your
library code your utility code and build
upon it or do you think about other code
contributors when you think about the
work that you do do you build systems do
you build applications do you build
models or you develop do you build
libraries and when you think about your
work product what do you actually pay to
do are you paid to write code or you
play to create analyses that require
code in order
to be run when you think about your
typical project is it 500 lines 5,000
lines 500,000 lines or or something
different and given the answer to these
questions your approach the survey may
be very different this is why we can't
take all of the result from the survey
and just plot them in the aggregate
because people are going to look at this
in a very different way now one thing I
want you to think about when you fill
out the survey the last thing I want you
to think about is are you filling out
the reality or you're filling out the
idealized version of the reality because
one thing that we found very useful when
looking at the results is figuring out
where the gap is between how we want the
world to work and how the world actually
works so I'll explain the handout to you
the baseline of the handout the two axes
are not completely independent but are
mostly independent and they're based on
the idea of how far does your code go
and what I mean is how far does your
code go in time is this code that lasts
for one day one week one month one year
multiple years now what that means can
be interpreted in a lot of different
ways one way to interpret that is if I
write some code is that no one ever
gonna look at it after one week or it
can it can think in the aggregate
amortized over the total lifetime of
this code how often does somebody look
at this so one thing that came up when
we were performing this this exercise
earlier was what about a script that
lasts for 10 years but people only look
at it once per year where does that fit
on that axis now the other axis is maybe
how far the code goes in space and you
can think in terms of people so who
touches this code who interacts with
this code who cares about this code is
it just yourself is it people who know
your name your team is it people who
maybe don't sit right next to you but
they sit in the same building on the
same floor they don't work on your team
but they see you and they see you at the
water cooler they see you at lunch is it
people who know your last name or they
know about your manager but they don't
know who you are specifically or is are
you completely anonymous to the end
users of your code for example for an
open-source library it's often the case
that the authors of the open source
library are not really well known by
their users and then maybe millions of
users know that the library exists but
don't know who's actually responsible
for it so let's go so I'm gonna start
with the survey we're gonna spend a
couple minutes filling this out
and I'll explain to you the elements of
the survey as we go let me get that
there and we'll zoom in a little bit
more with and the first air the first
item on the survey is pretty easy it's
when we talk about sophistication and
code we might talk about modular ization
so on these axis or is it appropriate
for code to just sit in a night Python
notebook it never or Jupiter notebook it
never leaves that notebook it's just one
notebook no Python modules and it just
sits there for number two on this graph
where is it appropriate to move that
code into a single file so it's a Python
module for number three where is it
appropriate for that module to be broken
up into a package for number four where
is it appropriate for that package to
become hierarchical like XML dot e tree
Elementary or many other packages you
know map pot Lib pipe lot or num pile in
algae and number five where does it make
sense for this to become a multi repo
with dependencies some fairly large open
source projects you install it and it's
actually broken up the utils is broken
up into its own utils package and it's
subdivided in that fashion so what I
want you to do is I want you to fill out
on the graph where you think these areas
are either as point masses as ranges as
clouds however you see this and then
I'll give you about a minute to fill
that out including those of you at home
and then after you fill it out maybe
we'll share some of the interesting
things that arose if the two of you want
to join me on stage
now if you feel like it's never
appropriate to write a Jupiter notebook
you can just cross that element out or
if you think there's other gradations or
other steps along the way as you add
sophistication to your process you can
add those as well what we're looking for
is we're looking to use this framework
in order to start you really thinking
about at what point do you switch from
one way of working to another way of
working at what point do you tell your
users no that's not good enough at what
point do you have to train scientists or
data scientists or analysts to do better
and where do you find that arguments
arise when you say you know what please
stop emailing me an iPod on notebook
please put it into a Python module
please please don't write all your
Python modules as single files please
break it up into a package and it should
be a fairly easy one for you now one
thing that we discussed as we ran
through this exercise is some of you are
filling out the way the world works
where you or you are right now some of
you are filling out how you want the
weight the world to work I think that if
we perform this exercise in the
aggregate across a division or a team we
could come up with some shared consensus
around how we want to write our code and
it could be something that we could use
to onboard new developers new co-workers
and colleagues or even set a baseline
for the users of our work product so
we'll take another minute and then we'll
go onto the next graph you want to do
one page and then we'll review and then
do the next page you want to graph my
graph okay so we'll take another 30
seconds and then we'll discuss this one
I think when we when we looked at the
results we saw that Daniel Brandon
myself Mike and the two Mike's who
filled it out all looked at it very
differently based off of the kind of
work we do one thing you'll see on this
graph is they're not quite independent
axes there's very few projects that
a million people that last for one day
and you can also see that this diagonal
here on this axis probably corresponds
something to the importance or the
priority so let's let's gonna wrap that
up and let's talk about any results that
people had I found that when I filled
this out my my I pi MB was really far in
this bottom left corner the moment the
thing was more than about a hundred
lines of Python code I moved it into a
Python module and I kept those notebooks
very small because I found that managing
on get the complexity of those was very
difficult anybody find anything that was
surprising when they were looking at
this or anything that they think might
be different than somebody else please
and there's there's microphones there we
can we can run them yeah test so I'm I'm
coming from a purely academic
environment and Jupiter notebooks are
kind of the way there he actually used
versus how they're intended contrasts a
lot to what you were saying you know
there are a lot of cases where a
scientist can do something very novel or
creative with 300 lines of code in the
duper notebook that they end up sharing
with a hundred people and then just cut
and paste that utility code between 50
notebooks exactly yeah and so I'm
guessing when you filled it out did you
fill out the reality or do you fill out
how you want the realities look I did
reality but but I think I think one
thing that's important when we look at
this very simple example as you can see
it's okay to keep all your code in a
Jupiter notebook if it's at a certain
scale or a certain size but then maybe
as you're communicating to the
scientists you can say look as you start
moving further along this diagonal that
there's some point past which you really
need to consider stop you know moving
your code into their place
let's take one more comment and we'll
move on to the next chart so we're
hearing a start up my co-founder did a
lot of stuff and I Python one person one
day impacted something that he was doing
and so I think of the the x-axis is kind
of like me is the two person like he so
he'd hand me
we'd ship a new model or need to do
something and I'd be like I don't really
want to deal with your ipython notebook
so let me script it and it's gonna dump
a bunch of outputs that are shippable or
digestible JSON configurations decisions
we made and then we autumn ordered
another engineer and he hated my things
in a single file and wanted it in like a
module and it was just kind of like it
we didn't even get we haven't even
gotten to five people yet and through
one two and three there's been a
different opinion about how that should
be done you know every single time that
you'll find in your organization's is
you may be more or less compressed in
terms of how many of these you draw
there are some liars who filled this out
earlier when we talk about testing a
documentation that said oh yeah one
person one day project I write unit
tests and full documentation and I put
into a git repo you're a liar that never
happens but maybe some people are a
little bit more compressed than maybe
waiting until they have ten thousand
people looking at their code before they
take it out of a notebook looks like a
look at the next chart so oh please
[Music]
can you call backup so one of the one of
the things I found that was interesting
was that for number three so three three
in you know one through three
specifically three well talked about so
I didn't really care about the the
number of people for for a multi file
package I mean didn't didn't really
affect the scaling too much there but as
soon as we got to four and five where we
have multiple packages multiple repos
dependency relationships the the the
number of people you know interacting
with that codebase really starts to
matter because you've got organizational
social communication issues going on in
coordinating on all those different
packages that depend on each other I'll
jump in and and say something off of
Andrews comment I I think we'll see on a
couple of these slides that there's sort
of an implied order of complexity that
often holds but does not always hold for
some people the notebook is the initial
scratch pad and the module is the
polished thing that you maintain for
others might start in a module and
prefer to just skip a notebook but
eventually get to an opal
as a polished piece of documentation or
teaching material that is elsewhere in
the hierarchy and we're going to see
that in future slides as well so with
that let's move on to the next slide
so the next slide is and this is
something that I think many of us
struggle with source control managing
source control we struggle with it in
our own lives and that every project you
start you actually create a git repo for
it at the very beginning or do you spend
a couple of days playing with it before
you say okay I'm gonna put it on github
so I'll tell you what these what the
parts we want to put onto the chart are
and these are not in any particular
order and they're not necessarily
exclusive they're not necessarily
quotations but where is it acceptable to
have no version control whatsoever where
is it acceptable to use tarballs or to
use - to final - 1py that's essentially
how the version control on this PDF that
I created was managed up until the very
last version you can see at the very
bottom there's a version number and they
get hashed that was a very that was a
last minute thing just so I don't feel
embarrassed by how bad the code and the
process for actually creating this talk
or at what stage do we need to start
using git or some version control system
if we're using git at what stage is it
okay for people to just use to get
linearly at what stage they need to add
branches what stage need to teach people
about forks and pull requests at what
stage do you need to start tagging
releases and be able to talk about what
those tags mean or what those tags are
tied to at what stage you need to teach
people about rebase at what stage might
you have the author not the same
distinct from the committer for the
project I think not a lot of people have
seen projects where the author and the
committer are not the same person but
there are projects out there that's
built in to get at what stage is that
okay I just have a local repo on your
computer and at what stage do you need
to make that code available to other
people on github and get lab or your
internal source control system and I've
seen a lot of different organizations
where you know it takes a long time
before code is made available outside of
the immediate working group I've seen a
lot of cases where weeks or months of
work are done locally and it's get is
just an afterthought to make that code
available because it's easier than
emailing it to people so let's take a
minute to fill that out and then we'll
discuss
they're not they're not distinct they're
not Devine these are not necessarily
distinct they're just different things
to put on to the to the diagram and
you'll see this through you'll see this
throughout in some cases there will be
multiple elements that can both be can
both be put onto the plot where they
they don't they're not exclusive of each
other give them another 45 seconds and
then we'll see if anybody came up with
anything interesting when they were
filling this out take another 30 seconds
so did anybody say was appropriate to
just never use version control cuz
you're a bunch of liars because I know I
know a hundred percent there's a lot of
projects that you do that are just in
some temp folder or in some scratch
folder there's almost certainly
someplace where you just don't bother
with it because it's harder it's it's
more work to use version control than
not now one of the people who filled out
the survey before told me that is not
the case for any piece of code he ever
writes I have asked if I can look at his
laptop afterwards to verify that myself
I'll just look for like a temp folder or
a scratch that py or something like that
maybe an Emacs buffer you never know at
what point do you need to start using
version control what's the what's the
baseline what do people think one day
for one person and then use you
immediately need to start using version
control yeah
that's that's a very so so that that's
Dan who's a graduate student that's a
very resume orientated approach
everything goes on github as many repos
as possible yeah so this is not the way
the world should be but the way I am the
my world is beyond somewhere between a
day in a week I have lots of point one
point one one point two ones and they
add ad infinitum
but like the moment it's more than one
person it needs to be something more
than that okay now one thing that's not
that's not out here but you can think
about extending extending this diagram
for is when you look at your git commit
messages at what point your get commit
messages go from fixed sundry list of
broken things to you know address PR
number 143 issue number 26 fix this with
a short message and a long message and a
description of that at what point do you
need to enforce people writing proper
get commit messages and at what point is
it okay to just be like fixed it tried
to fix it again didn't work typos you
know those you know 7:00 p.m. I want to
go home typo kit commit messages yeah my
comment Nathan software developer
so for me kind of similar along the
lines after one person and then there's
like you have to collaborate then it's
almost kind of like a requirement to use
like git and github for collaboration
but for like one person I kind of have
this this is almost like admitting
something bad like I'll set it up
and I'll start you know for one person
projects it might take you know however
a long time I'll work on it I'll I'll
update it but then because I'm the only
audience for it I just might not commit
my you know ongoing work so are your
users other programmers or they yeah but
this is this is like a scratch pad for
me or stuff that might be you know a
limited audience so it may be one so one
question is if you have technical
non-programmers like scientists or data
scientists at what point do you tell
them everything has to be in a branch
that's not developed or master if you're
making a change it has to be in a branch
branch often developed and we merge that
in and the very sophisticated involved
use of branches as opposed to you know
there's two branches one is Master once
developed never touch master that's only
for the release manager do everything
often development that's another
question that gets asked because on
projects on open source project where I
work with scientists they just work off
of develop because I can't get them to
create their own branches for things so
to me and when it comes to get once you
exceed something like an hour or two it
becomes worth it and and I have I think
I have a very good reason for this I
think most people misuse the the fact
that like once you get something working
you should just immediately just to
commands get in it get commits and now
you always have a rollback point also
that when you're going forward if you
break something don't you end up with
really messy history right so at what
point you tell people okay you need to
start rebasing your history to make it
clean and presentable once someone else
is gonna read it okay so because you'll
always remember your own history okay
yeah dan did you have something to add
well so this goes on long along the
lines of when do you bring out branching
and forks mhm
maybe not for us but mainly branching
so like I teach this 10-week summer
program at was I Virginia Tech and so we
have like these bunch of projects
they're roughly like five person teams
and last year I tried to shield them
from branches and just constructed a
project repository that's really
specific to limit the amount of merge
conflicts and then it turns out that
like after they all leave it's my job to
like make sure their code is working and
so this year to sort of prevent that
from happening we also there's like
undergrads we're on this project and
also grad students so the way we ended
up structuring it was okay we're just
doing branches and then the grad
students have to review these pull
requests and that really it's like the
only way you can somewhat enforce like
someone else looking at your code just
so like you don't have this 50 line for
loop or like 50 things copy and pasted
and just write a loop for it so that's
sort of you know a five person team over
the course of ten weeks like if that's
the scope of your project like use
branches okay anything anything else
anybody wanted to add were they they
feel like they may have written
something different than the prevailing
wisdom if not let's take a look at the
next one error handling is something
that comes up a lot you know I work with
a lot of test automation engineers when
I do corporate trainings and one
question is okay at what at what at what
level of granularity should we write
tests so at what point is it okay to
just say you know what Python doesn't
core dump just let it create a traceback
we can always cut and paste that into an
email and email whoever wrote the code
at what point is it okay to just do a
bear exit when something goes wrong at
what point you need to use the logging
module to emit logging info logging
debug logging got critical messages so
that when somebody cut and pastes the
output of your script into an email to
tell you it broke again you have a
little bit more information at what
point do you use try except at what
point do you actually care what kind of
exception you're catching and you you
pay attention to is this a type error is
this a value error at what point do you
bother with raise from wrapping other
people's errors using chained exceptions
at what point you say you know what my
library or my tool is so important I
need to have my own class
exceptions at what point do you say my
users keep running into the same common
problems let me create a page on my wiki
or my github repo with the common issues
people run into and the mitigations for
them and at what stage do you say we
have technicians in the field who are
away from their phone away from internet
for 10 weeks and we need to have
hexadecimal error codes and when you see
this error code you flip to this page
and the three-ring binder and you look
up this step and there's 10 pages of
mitigation and explanation like a
refrigerator repair manual from you know
1943 so let's try and graph those and
then we'll we'll take about a minute to
graph those and then we'll talk about
talk about that
skip to you know we'll get to forget to
look it because we have or skip will do
tap will do this one quickly then wilt
it will skip code sophistication so take
another another 15 seconds and then
we'll catch some feedback from you to
see
okay so let's let's get some feedback
from you before we do that I'll give you
my impression when I thought of this I
thought that the the y-axis doesn't
matter at all me it really comes down to
who's touching the code if the people
who are playing with this code know my
name I don't really need very
sophisticated error handling because in
all honesty irrespective of how
sophisticated the error handling is
they're gonna do the same thing they're
gonna tap me on the shoulder they're
gonna say it broke I'm gonna say okay
give me a second I'll fix it okay now
you can you can use it it's it's fixed
and only at the point where people don't
know my name or they have to send me
email so they have to post things online
do I bother with error handling more
sophisticated than the most basic that I
can do because only at that point do I
know that they won't be able to find me
or they won't be able to give me enough
information to sort out the error with
with with just a trace back and and
built-in error handling any other
thoughts on this one
any feedback anybody think differently
now you may find also that the axes are
maybe inappropriate for some of these
diagrams some people say you know what
it's neither the time nor the nor the
number of people who touch the code and
so let's move on to we all right we are
running close on time so let's run to
the next one we'll do testing and
documentation and then we'll kind of see
if this gave us any feedback so for
testing this is a very common one how
much testing is enough testing at what
stage are no tests ever appropriate is
it appropriate to just have manual tests
where you just run the script and if it
works it doesn't core downpour if it
doesn't give you a nasty looking trace
back message ship it at what point you
do doc tests at what point is it okay to
just have a shell script or a make file
that has all your tests in it at will
point to need a custom framework at what
sorry at what points you need a test
framework like PI tests at what point
you need a custom framework like an
extension of PI tests for example with
custom fixtures at what point is it okay
to just do holistic tests where you just
say I ran it to give me the same results
as last time versus unit tests which
look at only one unit of functionality
versus regression tests which make
richer comparisons between the behavior
as you see it today and the behavior as
you saw it at some baseline
when do you need integration tests which
look at how your code interacts with
other code including potentially code
that you don't write or maintain at what
point do you need fuzz tests so some
kind of sophisticated mathematical form
of testing at what point is it
appropriate to involve continuous
integration and if you have continuous
integration at what point do you need to
test all the possibilities of where your
code might be deployed all the different
platforms all the different versions of
all the dependent libraries all the
different versions of all of the
libraries that they might use you so
let's think about a minute to fill that
out and then we'll gather some feedback
from now what I want you to think about
as you fill this out is again if you
compare your results of the person
sitting next to you this is intended to
spark a discussion as opposed to create
hard and fast rules the purpose of this
this visualization is in the aggregate
if you fill out all the visualizations
and you look at them you'll begin to get
a sense of what your priorities are
you'll begin to get a sense of the
priorities that you want to communicate
to the people that you work with in in
one case we found that the person who
filled it out really really prioritized
testing really really thought testing
was important and honestly they even
thought a well tested piece of code was
more important than a piece of code that
had extra functionality I've worked with
people at companies like the move fast
and break things company and they don't
think that way at all they say marginal
functionality I want over marginal test
quality and ship it put it into
production if it breaks we can fix it
again tests are not important so take
another take another few seconds to fill
this out and then we'll get some
feedback from you ok any feedback this
is one I also feel very strongly about
and it drives me crazy every single
thing you write you have an i/o and
therefore you should always have a unit
test like you're gonna have to test your
code someway right whether it's just
gonna be a manual run or not like you're
not just gonna ship a piece of code
without at least running at once to see
if it works so you might as well wrap it
in a unit test
I will disagree with you there if you
ever work at a company with 250,000
employees I have seen circumstances
where you ship code without even running
it because you know no one's even gonna
run it themselves
but that's that's when you're getting
really cynical about the way that
organizations are structured she has
it's pretty yeah pretty terrifying so
for you everything is clustered in the
corner always right tests yeah and a
minimum to me the way I see it is it's
just like you're you're wasting your
time because you've already thought
through this you already know what your
IO is gonna be so you should have at
least one test that that checks to see
if your output is closed at what point
you write unit tests well I'm saying
like the the marginal effort to make a
unit test is trivial at least just one
unit tests are you saying multiple tests
for like all edge cases I think as they
like to properly write unit tests yeah I
think for me once you scale out past the
the five people mark and then you have
to start handling edge cases and just
throwing a unit test for each edge case
that that seems appropriate to me at
what point do you start measuring your
test output and say oh the test here
gave this result within this particular
variance of the previous test result
that's probably a heist kind of more of
a high scale thing like the hundred
people phase I think any any
disagreement or any any other thoughts
on we're testing is or is not
appropriate or what the curve for when
you introduce more sophisticated form of
testing I think just not about the age
of the code or how long I think it will
last but how confident I am that we're
not going to have to rewrite that part
because tests are a form of inertia or
technical debt that will have to be
rewritten if that part of the code is
rewritten that's probably the most
important factor for me I I'd have to
agree because if thing only lasts for a
week throw away the test throw away the
code yeah one of my favorite answers to
all the data science questions as it
depends right because it always does in
in this particular case most of my job
is just developing notebooks or analysis
that we need to present to the
leadership no I don't care about testing
at that
my quote to work enough for to be able
to present it to them in a particular
manner but then when you develop a
product that is going to be shipped
which is going to be seen by thousands
of consumers or hundreds of thousands of
consumers at that point you need all
those testing - mm-hmm fair enough okay
if there's no other feedback let's take
a look at one of the last ones that
we'll look at which is documentation so
where do you think documentation is
important or appropriate this is again
one of the things you can see is for
many of the characteristics at or from
any of the topics that we're looking at
trying to put onto onto these charts
there's always some competition in terms
of time you're always competing your
time as you're always you're always
trying to decide whether or not you want
to spend your time on feature
development or if you want to spend your
time on ancillary factors of the
software development lifecycle the
software development process any any
point of any amount of time that you
spend on testing or documentation is
time taken away from developing features
time taken away from developing
something that your users have asked for
and so when you talk about documentation
where is it appropriate to have just
self documented code where do you add in
docstrings at the class or the
functional level where do you add in
docstrings at the module level where do
you need your doc students to be numpy
or sphinx cough numpy doc or Sphinx
compliant when do you generate
auto-generated documentation and a read
the docs side and a really nice github
readme when do you write a man page when
do you need really narrative Doc's which
have an architectural overview or
development history where do you need
user tutorials
wouldn't need a QuickStart tutorial
where do you need to have documented use
cases in a code gallery like Matt
putlitz code gallery or the cold
galleries for many of the open source
projects that we use at what point do
you say this is complex enough that
somebody needs to write a book about it
almost every one of the open source
libraries supported by numpy no I take
that back very few of them very few of
them have books numpy has one pandas has
one matplotlib has one does any do any
of the other open source libraries have
books written about them I don't think
so and at what point do you need a full
university course if you think about
software like GIS their entire
university courses about these these
pieces of software because people need
to learn core concepts core mortar for
metaphors of the software itself does it
make sense to have
a University course about matplotlib or
have graduate students suffered enough
already
so we'll take another few seconds to
fill that out and then we'll see what
you think
now what I'd encourage you to do
especially for those of you who are too
shy to share your results with everyone
is look around and if you see somebody
after this talk is over and you want to
start a conversation compare your
results of their results and see where
they differ and see where your opinions
about these topics differ if you got the
same answer one of the two of you is
probably lying to yourself about how
often you write tests and really push
them and say do you really write tests
that often do you really write that much
documentation do you really care that
much about this or is that the way you
want the world to work if it turns out
that they are not lying and that is in
fact the way they want the world to work
and you want the world to work in the
same fashion maybe you should see if
there's an opportunity for the two of
you to work together at some
organization in the future okay any
feedback any thoughts yeah I'll actually
start on this one so I work at Capital
One mostly building models and doing
analysis and I work on a lot of things
that are regulated both internally and
externally by the government and so
there are very high expectations for
documentation if you do anything that's
going to be like in production and so
you're gonna have very smart people
internally and externally auditing your
code especially internally some of the
smartest people are the ones they get to
go poke holes and all of your arguments
and so if you don't have things well
documented it quickly becomes a blocker
and I've been in that situation where
I've taken over undocumented projects
and then had to defend them and so I'm
especially passionate about writing
documentation probably for anything
that's gonna be more than just me and
it's gonna last more than a week so
that's something that I do a lot of I
don't write any Doc's if you if you if
you can't understand what the thing does
it's not for you
and if you don't write docs then people
can't can't complain because they won't
they won't use your tool in the first
place and if you have no users you have
no no bug reports no pull requests no
problems missing from the list on the
right side is literate programming for
those of us who are literate programming
biased the documentation is the code and
I gotta say I've done some fairly small
things with literate programming and
some fairly big things with literate
program it's the biggest thing you've
done with literate programming there's a
repo you can look up called the no of
course I freeze it's called stingray
reader and it's I just moved it out of
SourceForge don't laugh to github and
stingray reader is several thousand
lines of code that parses COBOL copy
books and will convert em City data to
ASCII because I'm old and or several
thousand seven thousand and all done as
a literate programming exercise so it
started as documentation from which
working Python code is derived and it's
a it's a very large and very complex and
and nearly useless thing because who
needs episodic to ASCII conversion
nowadays so so do you feel like that
actually is that that style of
programming is a practical approach for
people to use on day to day projects or
do you think it's more of a interesting
idealistic exercise you ask an extremely
difficult question and I'm really glad
that a thoughtful person like you has
asked a question like that of a knob
like me next question please okay
because because one of the things that
you one of the things that I hope that
you're pushing yourself when you're
filling this out is to really separate
what is realistic from what is what is
realistic in the actual environment in
which you work and what is a realistic
ideal in the environment of what you
work as opposed to if you think about
these everybody knows more tests more
Docs is better nobody's gonna say oh
don't add more Docs if time and money
are infinite but given the resource the
extreme constraints on both industrial
and open-source projects you have to cut
something any other comments I have two
interesting points related to myself
which is one person three months
docstrings or just general code
commenting because I've found
assumptions of business logic or
something that I come back to after a
month and Mike what like why did I do
that
and then I read it and in that process
of rethinking through it I actually
write it down outside of code and then I
don't know if it's really up there I
don't really write docstrings but the
two person one week I would say just
like a readme which doesn't even really
document functions but documents
functionality and that almost
immediately happens after I share my
project with somebody else not often
like in the impetus of me but usually
they're like okay you you're like saying
the functionality out loud but like what
are the steps to get it working and I'm
like okay let me start your document
that or readme so somebody else can do
like the baseline stuff of something I
wrote one let's take one let's actually
hold off on those comments I'll do that
we'll do the last one then we'll take
all the comments at the very end just
for time so let's skip ahead and I want
to do just the very last very last one
at the top of the last page which is
supportive open-source I included this
so that they would invite me back to
speak at a future PI data conference so
this is that this is the token let's all
support open-source if yours if you're
working on a project that has a
dependency on open source project at
what point is it okay to just say you
know what get clone that's all the
interaction I need with that open source
project at what point is it upon you to
start reporting issues back to the core
developers
tribute by just telling them what's
broken at what point is it on you to put
the effort into submitting a pull
request to fix things which you know are
broken that you can fix this is
something that people in a lot of
environments really struggle to do I
know in corporate environments it is
very difficult to actually in an in an
open fashion contribute to these
projects because there's legal barriers
there's organizational barriers in place
at what point do you say you know what I
need to support matplotlib so much I'm
gonna give a little bit of money than um
focus as a contributing member or at
what point do you say we are so utterly
dependent on Jupiter notebook that we
need to convince our boss to become an
um focused corporate sponsor to ensure
that this tool is sustainable so let's
take 30 seconds to fill that out and
then we'll present our general findings
[Music]
Leah at what point is it appropriate to
become an unfocused corporate sponsor
if you're using the tools at all there
you go okay
so did anybody so so let's I wanna I
want to let you know what this last
section is there's two ways to think
about this last section just for sake of
time we'll present our conclusions and
we'll wrap this up I would love to hear
your feedback about this forum where
there was a useful tool to start
thinking about this or a useful tool to
communicate I want you to tweet at me
any results that you had on that because
I think it's sort a very interesting
discussion around these where you think
that maybe you you think different than
somebody else or you think something
very provocative about one of these
topics this last section is what do you
care about and there's two ways to
interpret it one way is what other topic
do you care about where you think that
there are quotations or choices that can
be made on these axes
Brandon filled out a really nice version
of it based off the reproducibility of
an analysis do you give somebody just
the steps and a readme do you actually
give them some automated way to
reproduce that is it okay to just give
them the results and have them try and
figure out how to reproduce it itself
the other way to think about this is how
do you categorize these different areas
in terms of how when you care about them
do you care about documentation only in
certain regions do you care about
testing only in certain regions at what
points you begin to care about something
so think about that tweet that at me I'd
love to see your response I hope this
has been a useful framework for being
and think about the issue as I said
please tweet at me or tweet at Brandon I
hope you learned something new who liked
this as a general framework for
beginning to think about this and I only
think about this but communicate this to
your co-workers the potential
organizations where you work to new
people let me see I rate a show of hands
who liked it very good so I hope you
learned something new about yourself I
hope you like this this is why do you
have to make it so complicated I'm James
Powell thanks so much to Dan Allen and
Brandon for helping me come together
with or put together this survey and
hopefully we can continue this
conversation after today see what you
think about these different topics try
to come up with maybe certain guidelines
that we might want to promulgate within
our organizations about when it's
important to do testing to do error
handling or across any any set of axes
in any particular topic that's important
to you let me take any final comments
from anybody
I don't know how well than it is but I
was just thinking that oftentimes if you
do really good unit testing it can kind
of take the place of documentation to a
certain extent because you demonstrate
how you intend it to be used
[Music]
I'd like to see this exact same thing
next year except maybe with like a
real-time poll so we could actually see
wherever why not we didn't would stand
there I'll be pretty cool we can we can
create more more things to fill out on
the graph as you as you put them in
there we can name and shame the liars
who tell us that they seriously oh I
write documentation for every five line
script that I write and I put it on
github with the full readme full set a
unit test night out I really like this
exercise because I've been thinking for
a while now that you know people that
write code and develop systems they
learn so much failure and that big nasty
project that you're like oh boy I wish
there was some documentation or I wish
every commit that was pushed to break
some something terrible via side effect
so I kind of like this because it made
me really think about all the biases
that I have sometimes for writing too
granular tests and maybe not documenting
enough so that it made me think think
about where I've been and you know what
things should be focused on and I want
to leave you with one last comment which
is if you're a manager and you're
thinking about this one thing is if
you're a manager you're going to at some
point bring on board some some young
programmer maybe fresh out of school and
they're gonna be very eager to please
and they're gonna want to do things to
get some positive feedback from you but
you may not have time to mentor them on
a daily basis and say you're doing a
good job you're doing a good job you're
doing a good job being able to
communicate to them the priorities that
and the relative prioritization of these
things can be very helpful and mentoring
them to tell them look
if you spent the whole week and all you
got done in this week is added more
tests that makes me happy because I
think tests are very important whereas
if you spent the whole week writing
documentation and it was for a
one-person project that is only gonna
last one week that doesn't make me happy
because I don't think documentation is
that important and so as you begin to
evolve your understanding of these
topics or evolve the way that you
communicate them through frameworks like
this you can help communicate to junior
programmers things which will make them
more effective it's a form of passive
mentorship and so I hope you like this
diagram I hope you like this
presentation thank you so much to Dan
and Brandon for helping me out and it
was my pleasure to present this for you
today thank you so much
[Applause]